les habitants ne sont pas autorisés à
sortir de chez eux jusqu'à demain matin
7h et c'est ce que dit le maire de la
ville les autorités pensent qu'il y à
une menace de frappes plus intenses sur
la capitale on l'a vu avant-hier
notamment avec le bombardement bien de
ce grand centre commercial qui a fait au
moins huit morts plusieurs immeubles
alentour ont été ont été détruits ce
matin nous avons entendu à plusieurs
reprises les sirènes d'alert sonné sur
ce réseau né dans la ville de kiev et
c'est vrai que c'est la crainte ici que
ce type de frappes dans la ville
s'intensifie parce que ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les fronts autour
de la capitale sont bloqués hier nous
étions à l'entrée dire pin donc ils le
feront au nord-ouest de de kiev et il y
a de plus en plus de tirs d'artillerie
mais malgré ces tirs d'artillerie les
forces russes tiennent deux quartiers et
ne font pas de progrès vraiment dans la
ville donc on voit ces fronts bloqué
hier il y avait là-bas des combats assez
limité entre forces russes et force
ukrainienne parce que maintenant les
forces ukrainienne et bien essaye essaye
de faire en sorte que les russes ne
puisse pas placer leurs positions
d'artillerie plus près de la capitale
donc ce qu'on voit se dessiner pour
qu'ils aient fait bien c'est la
possibilité d'un siège d'artillerie qui
dure et bien qui dure assez longtemps
avec l'emploi par les forces russes de
missiles et de plus en plus de frappes
dans la ville